[Music]
there's scientific evidence today to
show that we may be hitting the ceiling
of what the earth our home and the base
from what an economy can sustain without
causing surprise and potentially
catastrophic outcomes for Humanity so
the question is are we due stabilizing
the entire planet Earth is actually
lulling us into a comfort zone is doing
everything it can to stay in the
equilibrium where it has been for the
last 10,000 years which is the only
state we know that can support human
development the modern globalized
consumption based economy is hitting the
ceiling and causing major impact what
are the processes in the environment
that we have to deal with and cater for
at the global scale to allow earth to
support the maan economy in that context
science has developed a new framework
that we've called planetary boundaries
the analogy can be brought down to our
own human body at 41 or 42 degrees
Celsius of body temperature we also
change state from a living State to a
dead State a very distinct tipping point
so the planetary boundary is placed at
the 38 degrees Celsius equivalent the
bobbitt temperature which is the point
when you enter a danger zone it may
surprise you that among those nine
proposed boundaries is not only climate
change it's not only stratospheric ozone
which are obviously global it's also the
slow variables of biodiversity loss land
use change fresh water use which control
the underlying resilience and the
stability of their system all the nine
bound is actually interact whether we
like it or not we cannot deal with one
thing at a time you know when ice melts
it consumes energy so that the day when
the ice is gone the ocean heat will
start truly impacting on the atmosphere
so this is a a new panorama of global
risks on the environmental stage which
is not only about the environment but is
really about linking to society
we're starting to see effects on extreme
weather events particularly when it
comes to droughts and floods which are
influencing the world market price of
food which in turn propels riots and
unrest in many of the poorest urban
regions in the world so suddenly you can
no longer talk of environmental issues
here and social issues here a democracy
growth and ecology are today entirely
intertwined and and interdependent 196
countries now need to somehow move very
fast in the same direction it is
something more about leadership at the
global scale and how to achieve that I
think is the big big question I think
the time is so opportune right now to
rethink some of our governance
assumptions at international level and
this can be done even on an open market
so for example a global carbon tax or a
very strong cap-and-trade system so
business as usual is not the future we
need major transformative change my idea
based on science is that humanity needs
a great transition to global
sustainability within the safe operating
space of planetary boundaries a new
insight challenging science and
challenging societies for a safe future
you
[Music]